tenemos estos ejemplos para redondear a
la decena más cercana a la centena más
cercana vamos a tomar cada uno de estos
números y vamos a hacer el redondeo a
las decenas y a las centenas muy bien
comencemos con el primer número el 154
para reunir a las decenas vamos a
escribirlo aquí 154 tenemos dos opciones
redondear hacia arriba las decenas el
múltiplo de 10 que está por encima de
150 y 460 y el múltiplo de 10 que está
por debajo de 154 es 150 recordemos la
regla si vamos a redondear decenas
entonces tenemos que fijarnos en las
unidades o el número que está a la
derecha de lo que queremos redondear
vemos este número si es mayor o igual a
5 lo redondeamos hacia arriba si es
menor a 5 lo redondeamos hacia abajo 4
es menor a 5 así que vamos a redondear
hacia abajo hacia 150
muy bien ahora vamos a tomar este mismo
número pero vamos a redondear lo en las
centenas lo escribimos en la columna 154
ahora nos interesan las centenas por lo
que nos vamos a fijar en las decenas
esta decena es 5 es mayor o igual a 55
es igual a 5 así que vamos a redondear
hacia arriba pero aquí cuáles son
nuestras opciones bueno tenemos hacia
arriba la centena más cercana hacia
arriba o el múltiplo de 100 que está por
encima de 154 es 200 el múltiplo de 100
que está por debajo de 154 es 100 y como
nuestras decenas son 5 vamos a redondear
hacia arriba vamos a redondear a 200
fíjense la diferencia aquí cuando
redondeamos a la decena redondeamos
hacia abajo cuando fue la centenas
redondeamos hacia arriba porque esto
depende del valor que tenemos en la
posición que está junto a la derecha de
el número al que queremos redondear aquí
junto a las decenas en las unidades
tenemos 4 que es menor a 5 por eso
redondeamos hacia abajo
en cambio en las centenas vimos que en
las escenas hay un 5
así que redondeamos hacia arriba
analicemos la siguiente cantidad ahora
tenemos a 4 mil 674 4.674 en esta
columna vamos a redondear en las decenas
la decena que está o el múltiplo de 10
que está por encima de 4 mil 674 es
4.680 ya que está por debajo es 4.670
nuevamente nuestra red y ustedes pueden
pausar el vídeo en cualquier momento
para a ver paso a paso qué es lo que
estamos analizando aunque éstos
realmente son ejemplos de lo que hemos
visto en vídeos pasados de redondeo a la
decena o redondeo a la centena
redondeamos a la decena nos fijamos en
el número que está a la derecha en este
caso el de las unidades
tenemos un 4 aquí 4 es menor que 5 por
lo que vamos a redondear hacia abajo a
4.670 ahora analizamos el redondeo de
las centenas escribimos nuestro 4000
174 ay qué feo 6 674 con respecto a las
centenas nuestras opciones aquí son el
múltiplo de 100 por encima de este
número es 4700 y el que está por debajo
es 4600 ahora para decidir a dónde
redondeamos vamos a ver el número que
está a la derecha de lo que queremos
redondear en este caso son las decenas
tenemos 77 es mayor que yo así que
aplicar la regla de que redondeamos
hacia arriba a 4700 muy bien de nuevo
aquí pasó el anterior redondeamos hacia
abajo cuando estábamos redondeando a
decenas y en este de centeno redondeamos
hacia arriba damos el siguiente número
que es el 9 1995 en el caso de las
decenas escribimos 9 1995 redondeamos
decenas por lo que la decena hacia
arriba o el múltiplo de 10 arriba de
este es
qué curioso aquí tenemos comentar todo
esto va a ser 10.000 porque esto lo
aumentamos hacia arriba hacia 10 y por
lo tanto también va a afectar estos que
están aquí vamos a redondear hacia 1000
si fuera así arriba ahora en el caso
hacia abajo el múltiplo de 10 que está
por debajo de esta cantidad es 9 1990
muy bien usted seguramente en este punto
ya saben perfectamente cuál es la regla
si redondeamos decenas nos fijamos en
las unidades
este valor es 55 es igual a 5 por lo que
vamos a redondear hacia arriba nuestra
regla dice que si este número es mayor o
igual a 5 se redondea hacia arriba y en
caso contrario se va a redondear hacia
abajo en el caso de las centenas veamos
tenemos de nuevo 9 1995 ahora vamos a
redondear a las centenas la centena que
está por encima de 900 es 1000 pero esto
nos afecta a este 9000 que tenemos
juntos
diez mil coincide con este caso anterior
es el mismo número que redondeamos hacia
arriba en caso de que no se aplique la
regla y para redondear hacia abajo va a
ser nueve mil novecientos porque estamos
hablando de centenas aquí fue 9 mil
novecientos noventa porque eran decenas
nos interesan las centenas el número que
se encuentra junto a las centenas es las
decenas nueve definitivamente es mayor
que cinco así que vamos a redondear
hacia arriba también este caso nos
quedarán las dos que redondeamos hacia
arriba 9.995 redondeado a la centena más
cercana es diez mil y nueve mil 995
redondeado a la decena más cercana
también es 10.000 vamos a ver el último
número nuestro último número es ocho mil
346 voy a subir un poquito esto para que
nos alcance el espacio muy bien es 8.346
para las decenas el múltiplo de diez por
encima de esto es ocho mil
350 el múltiplo de 10 por debajo de esto
es 8 mil 340 si se fijan estos dos
números no los toco salvo en este caso
de que estemos llegando un 9 y el
redondeo me afecte los números que están
a la izquierda de lo que quiero
redondear pero aquí el 8 y el 3 se
conservan lo único que varía es lo que
se encuentra en las decenas que en este
caso lo que queremos redondear aquí los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo esto ustedes mismos que
seguramente ya lo deben tener bien
ubicada si vamos a redondear decenas nos
fijamos en las unidades en este caso
seis es mayor que cinco redondeamos
hacia arriba que es este caso 8.350 para
redondear a las centenas 8.346 nuestras
antenas 3 la opción hacia arriba la
centena por encima de esto es 8.400 este
8 no se vio afectado acá
el múltiplo de 100 por debajo de este
número es ocho mil trescientos hoy día
nuestra regla redondeamos centenas nos
fijamos en decenas este 4 es menor a 5
así que vamos a redondear hacia abajo
hacia 8.300 y aquí el redondeo fue
diferente a cuando redondeamos decenas
en decenas redondeamos hacia arriba en
centenas nos tocó redondear hacia abajo
yo espero que con estos ejemplos les
haya quedado todavía mucho más claro el
proceso de aplicar la regla para
redondear tanto decenas como centenas